[Music]
all right
yolanda yes yolanda where'd you grow up
where are you from originally
i grew up in los angeles echo park
echo park and uh tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents
growing up
no i didn't my dad was in prison
because it was a vehicle manslaughter
where he killed my mom in
a vehicle accident and they were
drinking
on father's day and he
was imprisoned so your mom died
my mom died i was one years old at the
time
so we were raised by my dad's parents
and we thought those those were my
parents so he came out of prison
and he was like this big old scary guy
and we didn't know he was our dad so you
were raised by your grandparents
my dad's parents you have my
grandparents
and um tell me about your childhood how
how would you describe it
my childhood was as a middle child
i was left out a lot um
it was average but i was very rebellious
person i was really i would
climb out the window i started using
acid i started using
drugs at like 14 and selling drugs like
when i was 15 16
um and it just became a lifestyle for me
and um
but when i got prayed with my son
i thought it would change it never
changed
i got praised by my son by an older man
he was 27 years old he was from the um
house angels and before
i realized that i was pregnant i watched
him get killed on tv
from um lapd because he was from the um
house angels and pulled him over
i guess he beat them up and ran and he
started shooting
and they killed him up there on
highland park that's when i found out he
was married
so she didn't let me go see him at the
hospital she just swore up and down that
was not his child
but
it ended up being his child she did come
and see him when when he
when i had him and she's like yep that's
that's
butch his name was bush and you you you
were old when you got pregnant
i was 17 17.
17 so did you finish school no
i went into the 11th grade but i was in
continuation
i was in continuation because i was
always ditching
drinking going to disney parties so now
you're 17 you have a child
i'm 17 i just had a child
and um
my family just took over they started
raising
him and all that stuff because i was
still
i guess not ready to be a mom
my sister took over my grandparents took
over
but bottom line is that my son loved me
unconditionally
no matter what i did no matter where i
was and no matter what
who said what they could never talk bad
in front of my
my son what he got i at the age of
9 10 he got he got caught in the system
and that's when he became
hard he just had to he grew up to be a
man real fast
you know at 14 i already had like a
little beard and stuff like that but
i used to go see him all the time but he
was very angry with me
he was really really mad at me because
of the fact that
he was living in a foster home didn't
understand what was going on
but it made him hard and that's how he
got into gangs and stuff
you know he became real hard so your son
became a gang member yeah these are
hispanic gangs
he became an uh an underground
man a hitman
for which gang um
and he was really like um
nobody knew his business the only way i
found out was because after he died
his homeboys came and told me what what
it was all about
there was a gang a gang that put a 187
on him because
he had like a shootout with one of the
kids and one of the kids was
their son and i knew their
parents so my son was carrying a big old
shotgun
with the trench coat at 102 degrees if i
knew there was something wrong
and they had 187 on him but what
happened was that before that was lifted
the guy that put the 187 on him army
ended being shot in the head at three
o'clock in the afternoon at an arco
station
um and then i found out later on that
that's how i found out that it was like
you know it was like a hit
and i was always wondering why you need
all this money all this money i was
[Music]
i didn't know until after he passed away
the real truth
but it's best that i didn't know because
he always carried guns with him i was
always at 45 smith and wesson
but when i seen him was a sawed-off
shotgun i knew there was something
really seriously wrong
i knew he was doing something and he
came to me to tell me
go talk to katie's parents being here
and blah blah blah you know
and i did i told you guys i'm in the
brick house
you know if i burn that house down or
something happens to my son and i burn
it down
the brick house is not going to fall
down it's going to burn everybody up
this is what i told because my son was
being threatened with it
with the 187 for something that their
son went
and when i pursued whatever it was
i just know that i had to protect my son
but it turned out that
catching a major case by the grace of
god the guy came and just dropped all
the cases
all the all the charges and i took him
to canyon country
and that's when um
i really don't know what really happened
up to this day
so your son passed away was he your only
child
no i i had my daughter of 88
and my daughter um
[Music]
my daughter when my son went into the
system
my sister suggested that i have my
daughter go stay with my cousin which
she couldn't have
kids and in the long run i was fighting
for her
but my cousin was really being
i mean i could understand excuse blood
she's blood family
but she wouldn't bring her to the
visitations
she would say that i didn't
go to the visitations that i wouldn't
make the appointments the schedules i'm
going to call
i would make no contact with my well it
turned out that
i went to prison and um i got a six-year
term
and went to bspw within that term
my sister told me that she got pregnant
at 13 years old
and then i i was hearing that she was
running away from home and
climbing out the window and like well
she has so good there why is keep
running away
why is she running away out the window
why should you
but what happened was that after my my
daughter passed away
she passed away in 2017 at 28 years old
um by train
and took a while to identify her but
my son she had my son's name her
brother's name
and that's what how we identified her
she had my her brother's name
tattooed on her you know but
when i seen my grandson and i seen her
stepfather
it was and there was no
no denying that they were father and son
so she was being molested by her stepdad
she was being molested by
by her stepdad robert
and um i always felt like i need to go
and do something press charges do
something kick his ass
shoot him in the leg you know cut off
his [ __ ]
dick or something that's how i felt that
as a mom i need to do that because of
the
the fact is that they took her to
arizona and
adopted her on under other rules
in a different state because here i was
not going gonna say it
but then when i found out about when i
found out she died
and i my cousin told me about that stuff
and i told my sister they said they knew
everything about it
that they knew that he could kick them
out they wouldn't let him go there but
he's here he is in the funeral
um wanted to take my spot when i'm the
biological mom
you know so i decided to step up and
take my grandson to the side
and tell him do you know who i am he
says no
i go your mom is my daughter
you always thought that the one that
raised her my cousin and this [ __ ]
was her parents but he didn't know
he knew that i was george's
mom george's brother's mom but he was
assured that that was the same
dad you know what i mean but it wasn't
but the fact it was the same mom
and i told him i told him that i was i
was his biological mom
i was her biological mom and you were my
grandson and
and do you believe that and this was in
church in the aisle
and he says yeah he goes what what do i
call you
and you can call me grandma yo yo so
when you seen us talking
what happened was after the services we
got we got to know each other because i
i never said at 14 he was 14 years old i
never met him
but that boy looked exactly like that
man
i wanted to cut his head off i want to
do something they would not let me
but i feel like i need to do something
for her in her honor because every time
i asked her go well who's the dad
who got she said she got gang right she
don't know who the dad
is she just made up these stories you
know and uh
they kind of like kind of like pushed
her out of the house put her in a mental
hospital
because she's crazy so they could keep
her son
and raise him as their own the same
thing they did to me
with my daughter they took me out of her
life
just to keep her and make her think that
was mom and dad
you know so that was really messed up
but um
so today you're you're down here on skid
row i'm on skid row
um where do you where do you stay
i still um outside julian
uh skid row housing and trust i've been
there since 2012 when i my last prison
term
um are using are using drugs today
yeah what do you use um
i smell crack and i drink and i smoke
weed
but um how do you support yourself
i have an income and um
i hustle
i've been um
i've been hustling um crack
for 15 years when you say hustling that
means you know
selling it buying it selling it back and
i was i
i was um doing that big time
but i got arrested through sales direct
sales
sales of nakhon blah blah blah blah and
i give my time i did
four four year terms and one six year
term but i think fire camp
fire department fire camp would be
but still there was it was time in
prison that i
i got used to i guess i can say
i don't i mean
i didn't have nothing else because when
i when i lost my son i lost my job i
lost my son
i lost everybody thought that it was my
my family thought that it was me
was a reason for my son passing away
because we never had a child die in our
family that was the first time ever
so that that made me look really bad
because i'm the mom
you know but i'm a single mom you know
and blah blah blah
and but my son he kind of came like
i want to say he was 17 years old and
the confidence were like
too small for him he was like six foot
three
235 [ __ ] pounds he was a football
frame
at 16 17. you know
so that right there was like a big loss
and everybody i have a really big family
and they just turn around
and um after losing all that you would
think you know family
would come in and help well
it didn't happen that way they just
looked at me like
you know it's your fault that your son
should have never you're supposed to die
before yourself or whatever
now that my daughter died now whose
fault is that right
when you got she didn't get hit by a
train directly
what happened was that i remember seeing
it uh
on online when they were showing it on
the news but i didn't really i
didn't really trip that it was my
daughter right
but after after i realized wait a minute
i've seen that and the way they
described it
that had to be my daughter so she's
walking down
the track with the freight trains code
not not metrolink or nothing but freight
and the conductor said in this in a
statement saying that
we seen her walking her hair was down
her hair was really long
and he was like you know blowing the
horn
and it seemed like she didn't even hear
her to pay attention to it she was like
didn't have no id no nothing like she
was just walking down
so i guess the train kept going and um
at the end of the train the caboose i
guess was
bigger than the train the back of it
and and it like it hit her and then
nicked her
and it and scooped her up into the
tracks
but we mangled and mangled her and
everything so
identifying her they had a hard time
identifying her
but um this would happen like in
november
last like almost thanksgiving
of 2017 and we find out it was her until
like december
and then uh we had the services december
11th because my
my sister was going to pay for it but
the thursday before that
before that that day my sister
went into the emergency room at kaiser
she's my only sister
she went for some blood clots they had
an operation
she went to ic she was in icu
intensive care and so that saturday or
sunday i want to go see her
and um it was unbelievable to see my
sister like that
she's she's just like always been to
work but what happened was that she told
me oh
don't look like i'm gonna make joyce's
own services
her ease i know i know becky
and she um
i went to the services monday
and tuesday morning tuesday afternoon
the next day at three o'clock
they called me and told me my sister
passed away
that got me uh i mean my sister
she she provided you know she i was she
i always wanted her she i was in
depending she did
how do college put me under
tax returns stuff like that
but is losing your children and your
sister
worsened your drug use or your
your mood or depression or anything it
is worse
it is worse because you know for real
surreals
[Music]
i don't know what i'm living for
you say there's a purpose
why are you taking the people that don't
deserve to go
but i'm the one that had that corrupt
life the one that i've been down here
i'm
doing drugs this and that just just
doing things that
at any time that you know your life can
end you know
for whatever reason it is
thank you but for whatever reason it is
um i continue to
to have that big heart just like right
now you know
um my relationship is
really a
very abusive relationship you're an
abusive relationship now
yes i know i'm a victim of domestic
violence i'm restraining orders
and protective orders from the judge and
they gave me a reasonable accommodation
to move
out of the place that i'm at to another
place because that person seems
to be able to have that way to come in
and out anyway
anytime they want to and uh
i mean just i bang bang bang bang bang
i'm gonna kick down almost try to creep
and nobody says [ __ ]
nobody does says nothing nobody does
nothing nobody
calls nobody nothing knowing how severe
and how aggressive that person is being
you know what i mean and uh
and it's that's why i'm out here at this
time
today because i have a place to live i
have a place to go
i'm not there because he's there
and i don't want to be there
do you think there's anything from your
childhood or anything in your life that
kind of
created a lot of the dysfunction a lot
of the tragedy that you your life has
seen
i think i think we are learning about
um
you know the death of my my mom
um and how my dad
um
i mean nobody told us he made us think
that
my grandparents were our parents
when that man came into our lives he
scared me he scared me because he was
a very scary man your dad
yeah my dad was a very scared man he was
he looked like a chief
you know like oh right now
just a real big ugly teeth i know
are you american idiot yeah
yeah i'm american indian um
but what what uh we're trying never hold
trump
yeah arizona
i'm here today on skid row
i know a lot of people down here i have
people don't have grudges against me the
only thing they do is they hate on me
because
of my rapport you know i mean when
when you sell drugs down here and and
it's a good thing and you do good
and you treat people good and you don't
forget about your people they don't
forget about you you really don't
you know but it's just about that it's
not all about that
then when i got my place i don't think
there's any one person
over here that i didn't let him come
over and stay
feeding while she you know give him some
clothes take a shower and get some
i don't think there's one person that i
didn't do that for because
why not you know
but just a relationship that i'm in
he um he did a manslaughter right across
the street where i lived
which i wasn't there yet but this is
what i heard and he killed somebody
but the person didn't die until he got
to
the hospital so it became a manslaughter
so we offered him 17 years and not in
life
who's not going to you know jump on that
right so
he did so whenever i met him
after he got out i really met him
it was more like just getting high kind
of thing
and then that's when i had my accident
when i broke my femur bone
and i went to the hospital i had two
major surgeries
um got a titanium rod in my leg and it
was funny that
this man that i know from a can of paint
i just got out of prison
stood there took care of me
and that's when i got hurt and i met
this guy and it turned out that we got a
little bit close
and now he's became abusive
that's why i'm not even home right now
and um
and as you can see if you can see my
yeah your eyes
black and blue is from him
so what what is your biggest face right
now is it alcohol or
crack or what alcohol alcohol is your
big deal
alcohol because um i'm a severe
depression
um i got um accepted for exercise for my
mental i thought it was gonna be
physical
i didn't think my mental was that bad
and i think the traumatizing of my
children
you know the traumatized becoming a skid
row and not being
raised i'm going down here and just
i'm just actually living through this
i've been here since
seeing my daughter i'm 88 when i came
down here for sure
and that's like a long time you've had a
rough life
yeah i had a rough life you know but you
know at the same time it's like
i don't know what is a rough life you
know what i mean
all right yolanda thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome
good luck with getting away from the guy
oh yeah
yeah today if there's nothing this
weekend i have to deal with
maybe i'll just get me a room and stuff
like that just for the weekend
by monday that later has to be here
i'm waiting for like an income
verification